greetings from podcastville it's
wednesday the 14th of april
the joint is brought to you by zip
recruiter
listen good help is hard to find you
know that it's like trying to find a
[__] needle in a haystack
sure you can post your job online or at
a cork board
down at the [__] coffee shop but then
you got to sit there and hope the right
person walks by and sees it
stop dreaming and try zip recruiter for
free
at ziprecruiter.com joey listen whether
you have a small business
or a huge business with 200 employees
zip recruiter
is for you why because one click and
your job gets sent to over a hundred of
the top job sites
and here's where it's get freaky their
matching technology
hooks you up with the people with the
skills and experience
that you need in fact zip recruit is so
affected
that four out of five employers who post
on zip recruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day 2.3 million businesses have already
used zip recruiter listen
you know what zip recruiter is about
time and money it saves you time
and money and lets you do as a business
owner what you're supposed to be doing
so do me a favor right now
you can try ziprecruiter for free joey
what are you talking about
ziprecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
slash joey that's ziprecruiter.com
joey try it for free give it a shot take
a chance columbus did
just by going to ziprecruiter.com
joey save time money energy and get the
right candidate for your job
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
the joint is also brought to you by on
it listen may 3rd through the 16th
honor is having this semi-annual [__]
sale
this is the biggest blowout of the
[__] year
alpha brain alpha brain powder shroom
tech
new mood protein bars apparel
they got some new stuff coming out which
i got to get all the
right information on all i know is honor
is the company for you
anytime who got me out of the slump when
i moved to jersey
alpha brain i was over here mumbling and
stuttering like [__] you know
alpha brain healthy i went on a six-week
[__] cycle
you're looking at me i'm looking thinner
it's shroom tech that's helping me get
better
workout results why am i sleeping better
new mood
i rotate that in my sleeping you know
this is it
at night why am i losing weight because
i'm not eating salami sandwiches
what am i eating protein bites 7 grams
of protein
low sugar honor is the company for you
go to their website right now
take a look at their supplements take a
look look at their kettlebells their
club bats
take a look at what they're seeing this
is a company of health
go order alpha brain the reason why i've
been with honor for 10 years is because
of one thing
alpha brain that product they have a
hundred percent money back guarantee and
they don't want the product back if it
don't work for you
when somebody does that they're telling
you a commitment so go to honor.com
right now
look read read about alpha brain read
about shroom tech
new mood they have so many great
products that could help you out
if you don't like pills they got the
instant powder and it tastes [__]
tremendous
you see i ran out of the other ones so
go to honda.com right now
take a look at what they got press in
church or joey and get 20
10 10 delivered right to your [__]
house all right who's better than you
nobody go to honor.com right now let's
start this [__] podcast it's a
wednesday
and we got a lot to [__] talk about
here candles are late [__]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
[Applause]
greetings [__] it's wednesday
morning hope you guys are doing great
no guests today you guys are [__]
happy than ever
everybody complained we want joey no
more [__] guests
i try to bring you guests i told you
this is a hybrid [__] podcast it's
gonna be different every week we're
gonna come at you from different
directions
to keep you [__] surprised and that's
it and that's that
let's talk about this [__] can you
believe this [__] finally i go through a
[__] vaccine
and it's giving people blood clots this
is what i'm talking about people do you
understand what i'm trying to say to you
why the [__] would i go up there
now i was happy down here minding my own
business nobody had covered
now i go up there now i'm getting
[__] calls that [__] johnson and
johnson's getting blood clouds let me
tell you something i didn't even get
a [__] reaction from it i got a
headache the only thing i did
get was this happened to me sunday night
and it was [__] terrible
i don't even know if i told you mike i'm
sitting here we're watching tv my wife
goes to [__] bed
you know we watch our two episodes of
cobra kai with mercy
we come down i come downstairs you know
i get my ice pack
i get the [__] pins i put it on my
knee and i watch tv for a little while
when i have the ice back on and the tens
i make a few [__] calls you know i
check in with george i check in with
leah checking with some other buddies of
mine
and then i watch tv for a little while
and then when i get bored of tv
i practice the [__] guitar by that
time i make a tea
i'll drink a sleepy time tea or drink my
kimono tea
yeah i should get sleepy time what are
you [__] nuts they do have this
sleepy time it's [__] tremendous
nappy new new time i drink my little
sleepy time tea
and i come downstairs and i play the
[__] guitar for a little while
and then when i feel this i go upstairs
and i [__] go to sleep right that i
swear to god that's the same story every
[__] night
some nights i pop a new mood i keep it
[__] cause listen
my body gets used to everything that i
[__] take so if i take
tryptophan i can only take it two nights
then i gotta switch to melatonin
from on it then i gotta switch to kikomo
has a [__]
uh thing a texture tincture that you put
under your tongue
i switched to that two nights a week and
then chong sent me a [__]
cbd that also sleepy time
that i [__] do that i do a little cbd
lion the [__] helmet
so i gotta rotate my [__] sleeping
stuff every night i rotate it
so i don't get used to it so my body
doesn't get used to it people always say
oh just drink [__] melatonin that's
great i drink melatonin
for one to help with the covert or honey
that has it and number two because it
helps you get better sleep
six [__] sprays i do twelve i'm not
gonna lie to you
i do twelve to go a little deeper into
the [__] murky waters of the
underworld
dog i [__] hate getting up in the
middle of night my biggest problem is i
get up in the middle of night how many
times i've got in the middle of the
night
and the last three months maybe five
times and that was because of the knee
what i would do is i would go to bed
pissed off about something
and then wake up at four in the morning
and i would [__] god
damn it and i would go downstairs this
is when i lived in l.a i would write i
got myself into writing
whatever the [__] was bothering me and
within two minutes you're in bed
that's it just write it out if you wake
up in the middle of night don't turn the
tv on
don't get involved in something just
[__] go downstairs
take out your journal start journaling a
little bit and [__] you'll go back to
sleep so
sunday night because everybody kept
telling me you're gonna get reactions
from the [__] shot well i left
tuesday and wednesday open last week
tuesday at 10 o'clock i was at the gym
on the [__] bike
and i'm like what the [__] is going on
i'm supposed to be tired right now it's
severe nausea thank god i got my [__]
relief banned
this [__] is gonna be with me
forever i got no [__] nausea so
i went to the gym 20 minutes you know
not nothing went back
wednesday i left wednesday open too
nothing so i didn't get any [__]
symptoms so i'm like
well but i had a little bit of a
headache i've been getting a little bit
of the [__] headaches
so what i did was i said [__] i've just
been taking tylenol
and i'm like [__] this headache has been
lasting a little bit more than usual
that's the only side effect
i could complain about now sunday night
was completely different
i did my little nappy nunu tea i did my
sleepy time i didn't even do thc that
night just to let you guys know where i
was at that night
i said tonight i'm gonna give thc a
break i'm just gonna go with the [__]
melatonin
and i'll drink some sleepy time okay
i [__] come downstairs now in the
basement
i've been i this is why i rehabbed you
know i have the [__]
chair that you you go all the way back
like a zombo recliner and you sit there
like an old man i watch tv
i put ice on my knee i put some tins on
my knee i watch tv
i did all that [__] [__] sunday night
i'm sipping my tea
between us i probably took five
sips of the tea there was still half of
it great flavor
and i took the melatonin i'm laying
there
and it's starting to get [__] hot in
here right i'm like [__]
i got a hooded sweatshirt on i got my
t-shirt underneath regular t-shirt
and i got the heater 10 feet away from
me but i got the screen door behind me
it's usually a little cold in that area
you know what i'm saying but that night
i'm like [__]
it's unusually hot man and also i'm like
[__] i'm gonna take my sweatshirt off
i take my sweatshirt off i'm down to a
t-shirt
i'm like [__] it's hot in here i get up
i turn off the [__] heater
i sit back down again i don't even know
what the [__] i'm watching
i'm just sitting there and all sudden i
start sweating
just sweating out of nowhere
perfuciously just [__] sweating i'm
like what the [__]
is this [__] and i'm like [__]
awesome i take my t-shirt i'm downstairs
sitting there with my tits out
like on that plane that time with
gabriel i'm [__] wiping my head off
i'm sweating i tried to pick i didn't
know what the [__] to do
you know i had some water on my on the
right side you know like a little bottle
of water i had there
i had my little sleepy time tea on the
left i started drinking the water i put
some on my head to cool me down
and next thing you know i woke up it was
one like in the morning i must have
[__] passed out
so whatever reaction i had to the
vaccine i think it was that
i wake up monday morning everything's
fine i go to the gym
my first 20 minutes 30 minutes at the
gym were a little rough
by the time me and mike did the podcast
i was okay it went through
boom [__] this morning i wake up and
it's all over the [__] news
that you know j j is causing blood clots
you know me dog i got a clinic right on
[__] hand
i called the guy up i'm going for a
[__] blood test later on today
he told me you know because i don't have
to stress the [__] not eating
that's what kills me about blood tests
when they tell you you can't eat in the
[__] morning and then you have to go
in that's when i faint so i'll go for a
[__] blood test i don't have no blood
clots i've been riding the bike every
[__] day i don't take a [__] day
off that goddamn bike so
if i get a blood clot i don't know you
know me i'm on blood thinners i take a
baby aspirin every night at 8 o'clock
with my dinner to prepare me because
it's 12-hour coverage
for your [__] heart so can you
believe this [__] i go up and get a shot
that i'm [__] listen
i'm not an anti-vaxxer i'm not a [__]
conspiracy theorist i just wanted to
make life easier for everybody around me
i wanted to make life easier for my wife
i wanted to make life easier for my
daughter for mike
now i could go out now i could venture
out and enjoy jersey
that's why i went up then did the shot
now you're telling me that the [__]
shot caused his blood clots
so now i'm thinking like the needle
didn't even hurt so now i'm thinking
about going and getting the [__]
modern
one two shots of that [__] and going
through that again so what i'm going to
do is this i'm going to [__] check
for blood clots i'm going to get my
blood drawn
and i'm going to have them do an
antibody test and then we'll take it
from [__] there okay so
i hope nobody worries i've been
exercising every day the whole [__]
thing i guess
i read this j thing and it's creating
some type of like a stroke effect but
let me tell you guys what happened
10 years ago not even when i was 50
you know who i'm surrounded with out in
l.a i was surrounded with a bunch of
[__]
health nuts and one of them told me to
[__] go on testosterone
i went to the doctor i did a blood test
my doctor's like
your testosterone is fine he goes in
fact it's even better than what it
should be
you're fine but against his best wishes
i went to a testosterone doctor because
my healthy buddies were like
you got to go to get testosterone you
got to get testosterone you got to get
testosterone
so i started doing a little shot of
testosterone every day was all legit
a doctor did it up in [__] van nuys i
went to see him once a [__] week
and i started putting on weight i'm
supposed to lose [__] weight
i went from three [__] 15 to three
[__] 30. i'm supposed to be losing
weight on testosterone
i'm the only fat [__] that's gaining
weight i'm [__] testosterone
even though my [__] acupuncturist
told me she goes don't do that [__]
testosterone
you don't need it trust me right now you
don't [__] need it at all i kept
doing the [__] testosterone
i went to dc i had a migraine headache
for like three [__] days
i finally couldn't take it no more i
went to the doctor and they told me i
was creating too many [__] red blood
cells
so they had to drain my [__] blood
you didn't want to be around me that
night
i must have fainted 18 [__] times
okay when i looked up and saw the tube
connected to me and that they were
drawing blood into that [__] tube i
nearly fainted
so i know all about that [__] so i'm not
going back for that at all
i'll go this afternoon i'll take my
[__] little blood test
they'll check for blood clots they'll
check for [__] to see if i get the
antibodies in me
because i didn't feel nothing in that
[__] needle who knows what was in
that [__] bottle
you know so for me i just want to be
double safe
and i just want to show you because
couple people checked in with me thank
you very much guys
you guys knew i did the [__] i had
some nice emails people saying
because you did it you encouraged me
whatever you know there's a lot of anti
there's a lot of [__]
hate going on out there i just did what
was best for me
and my family if i want to do stand-up
in the future whatever the [__] i don't
want to have to do
i don't have to worry about it because
i'm vaccinated you know what i'm saying
but if it's only going to last six
months
and i'm gonna have to get a boost anyway
in september to go to the premiere of
the sopranos
it looks like that's what i'm gonna
[__] do okay number two i want to
talk to you some about
something people you [__] that
keep hitting me up
about sharon osbourne let me tell you
something i don't know nothing about
sharon osbourne
i don't want to know none about sharon
osborne i don't mess with sharon osborne
i've never met sharon osbourne i've
never met ozzy osbourne
and i keep to myself i had an
opportunity one time
to meet them and i was like let me think
about it and i said let me just pass on
it for right now
i love ozzy too much and i'm scared to
say the wrong thing in front of [__]
sharon
and i don't want to end up [__] dead
do you understand me when it comes to
sharon osbourne those [__] will kill
you
sharon osborne's about to go [__] off
any week now
she's about to go off i don't know they
fired her on the view
you know after 10 years she's got a lot
of [__] to say
i don't know sharon osbourne i've never
met sharon osbourne
i'm sure she's a very lovely lady i read
the book
the man who led zeppelin by peter grant
and it was the peter grant's biography
and peter grant learned everything he
knew from sharon's [__] father
who was a manager who was black
sabbath's original [__] manager
who robbed them and all that [__] again
no disrespect to sharon osborne i don't
want no problems with sharon osbourne
i'm just saying what i read in the
[__] books here okay i'm just
repeating what i read in the books here
i don't want no problems with sharon
osbourne i'm just saying
that uh i don't know what happened on
the view do i look like i watch
daytime tv why do people keep asking me
this [__]
do what do you think what do you think i
do all day just sit around and watch the
[__] news i hate daytime television
every time i put the tv on in the
daytime i'm like what the [__] is going
on with my life
throughout this pandemic i knew that if
i turned the tv on in the daytime i
would die
i knew if i turned it on i would die so
that tv doesn't even think
of [__] going on till 8 o'clock at
night so i've never watched a [__]
view
i love cheryl underwood i've known
cheryl for 20 [__] years
she's a phenomenal comic i don't know if
you guys knew that she was a [__]
tremendous stand-up comedy cheryl is a
[__] force to reckon with
so i don't know what happened i don't
know what went down i don't want to know
and i don't know if so so you people
that keep asking me emails
if sharon wants to come on the osborne
if sharon wants to come on a podcast and
talk about what happened
you know me i'll take it with open arms
but besides that i don't know nothing
about sharon osborne
i've never met her and i don't want her
because i don't want to say
the wrong thing and for her to [__]
go off on me or whatever i don't need
that in my life
i got no problem with english people and
meghan markle
and [__] pierce morgan and the king
of wales i got no problems with these
people
i don't know these people like salud
whatever the italians say
whatever go enjoy yourself i don't know
what the
you about i don't know a bunch of people
like what do you think about sharon
and don't ask me i'm [__] public if
you're gonna dm me about
dm me about me i don't even want to put
sharon osbourne on twitter
i don't want to write i didn't want to
write sharon never mind i was born
i don't want nothing to do with these
people because they'll [__] sink your
boat i'm scared of sharon osborne
if you you know how women are scared of
[__] uh harvey weinstein with the
missing teeth
like now he's missing four teeth he's
got a pneumonia
they did they put that [__] on twitter
like to make you feel bad for harvey
weinstein
he's missing 14. well now he'd get
better head in [__] jail because you
know he's giving head in there
they got that little 60 year old man
they're smacking him suck my dick harvey
hobbies over there gumming them to death
that [__] i don't know
i don't know we're talking about sharon
osbourne
also we end up on harvey weinstein with
no teeth this is what i'm saying guys
i'm back you understand me that's how
you know i'm back
i'm survived covered and i'm [__]
harvey survived cold beverage scandal
yeah bobby's gonna get cold but who
gives a [__]
when he was raping women he wasn't
worried about [__] coving so now
[__] him but he's trying to do his fight
extradition to california i read that
somewhere that they're gonna
actually die what the [__] for the
damage is done
he's already gonna [__] die in jail
you wanna actually down to california
and do what give him 20 more years they
already gave him two thousand [__]
years he's gonna run under the cell poor
[__] harvey
and all that money can't save him [__]
him that's what happens
[__] torturing hollywood [__]
actresses
again i don't know about sharon osborne
so that's
i don't know i want to know and this is
what's going on
but in a brighter note i do want to talk
to you about what's going on in my life
this is going to be a
a big-time [__] podcast today you
know
i love doing what i do and i love
i love talking to a lot of you guys you
know
you guys know it there's a lot of years
that have relationships with me on the
internet we've never met
and we have great conversations whether
on it's on facebook
whether it's on patreon whether it's on
twitter you know you guys
go back and forth to me i read your
messages you know i read your stuff
whenever you post at a family member or
something
i always say prayers or candles lit
just to give you a gleam of hope you
know
i believe that people deserve you know
hope you know
when when somebody pours them when
somebody puts something stupid on
facebook that's one thing
but there's people that actually are
honest on facebook and they they write
what their real feelings are on [__]
facebook and some people
you know say stupid [__] to them when
somebody
has the balls to not dm you
but to put on there i'm having a rough
day today
my father's dying it's not for people to
go you know
[__] you or whatever and i've seen it on
facebook
even if i don't know that person i'll
stop and just go hey man prayers lit
or just something just something to let
them know
to let them believe it you know because
i've been there i know what it's like
this last year or two whatever
we've all experienced some form of death
and it
never you never [__] think about it
until it hits your backyard but with
everything that's been going on there's
been a thousand [__] bets and all of
us
have heard a story of somebody or or
something
you know and it's finally hit me over
here
you know when i got off the plane i i
feel that
me moving here
was meant to be you know i'm very happy
about my decision i have no
regrets at all whatever happened
happened great 23 years it's on to the
next chapter of my life whether we do
stand-up whether we do movies
whether we get into theater whatever the
[__] i do i don't give a [__]
i'm happy my family's happy my wife has
had my daughter's happy but
things have happened in my camp too that
i don't put on facebook you know i just
tell you guys in the podcast you guys
are my [__] psychiatrist
you guys lift me up you know that's why
i lift you up or i try to lift you up
whenever you're down um in 1981
listen man i've had 20 [__] moms
i don't know about you guys i've had 20
moms
most people have like a mom a grandma
and then like a friend's mom or a
mother-in-law i've had 20 [__] moms
from marianne balzano to anna bender
to joan ronnie to to mitzi shore to
[__]
my godmother you know i've had so many
women
strong women that have been in my
[__] life
you know what i'm saying i'm very
[__] fortunate about that
you know in life you never really get to
say goodbye to somebody
it sucks it sucks that
you i never got a chance to say goodbye
to ralphie i never got a chance to say
goodbye to brody but you live with that
and then you make your own piece and you
mourn and
life goes through with that well this
week i had to do
what you guys have been doing for the
last year and that's
putting somebody down you know i'd have
to put somebody down at all
um when i got back here you know i was
really happy about
my plan was to come back here and thank
anna bender and joan ronnie for taking
me in when i was younger
anna bender took me in 1979
and then i had a problem at the house my
behavior
and i you know i had to leave and i had
to find a different place to
live i didn't know what i was going to
do with my life and the ronnies took me
in
the benders of the ronnies are two great
families in boulder
boulder and north bergen north bergen
has a
had a ton of great families when i was
growing up the dilorenzos the benders
the runnies
the tizios the the azkalis i mean there
was so many
big-time families that helped me out the
lebranos you know they all [__]
mrs lebron was a mom to me you know but
in 1981
it was a different coco um
and mrs ronnie took me in mr and mrs bob
ronnie took me in
his name was robert and her name was
joan
uh joe josephine joan is my sister
her daughter and they had four boys and
i considered them all my
my brothers when they took me in they
took me in april
21st of 1981
and it's april 12th of night of 2021.
that's 40 years that they've been in my
life and i'm
[__] proud you know for all you
people who think that uh
yeah i was a criminal and all that stuff
but i was still a human being
and i never forgot the people who took
care of me it was very important
for me to not forget about these people
i didn't want them to
think that their love towards me was in
vain do you know what i'm saying like
you never want
like when a comic helps you like if
you're a young comic and an older comic
helps you
you want to do well to make them proud
of you so later on
in the career they'll say to you you
know what you could go up to them and go
thank you like the way i do on podcasts
with different comics
that have helped me over the years
whether it's joe or
whether it's greg fitzsimmons or whether
it's theo a ton of comics have looked
out for me you know what i'm saying so
in life a lot of a lot of women looked
out for me when i was growing up
and i'll never forget the ronnie's
coming to me and going hey
we talked to our mom and dad it's okay
if you you can move
in with us and i'm going what the [__]
you know
how do people open up their houses to a
stranger
i knew mrs running she was the crossing
guard at the high school
and i always said good morning to her i
was always polite to her
and here two years later i'm gonna move
in with her you know what i'm saying i'm
like
thank god i was always nice and sweet
and she remembered me and whatnot
but you know as soon as i got back here
i got back august
19th and september 5th her son
mike his wife passed away
and there was a party and we all went
down there that saturday and we saw mike
i went to the wake you know the whole
[__] deal
and then my family i mean they are my
family
no matter how you cut it and then since
they were in tom's river
they're close to me mrs ronnie i've been
down there a couple times to see her say
hello
i brought her some italian cookies you
know i ordered those tins for christmas
and i brought her some of those
i've gone this i've gone down there a
couple times now
she's old you know she's been sick for
years
you know she's had a cancer
for like 10 years so she's had it under
control now i went there easter
i took i went down there with my wife my
daughter we went down there for the
early half of easter
like for an hour just to sit with them
mike came down
steve came down and some of the boys
were there and i go down and i and we
ate some sandwiches we got some [__]
great italian sandwiches
and we ate them when i went down there
easter sunday i don't know
check your calendar i don't know what
day easter sunday fell on
but it was she was in great shape we
were talking
we were having a great time talking
about this and that
and this and that and all of a sudden i
get a call
maybe yeah four weeks ago i get a call
maybe
three days after easter that she's
having a hard time
you know i said if there's anything i
could do blah blah blah blah they just
called me to tell me they rushed to the
hospital and then
then when she came home we went back
down there and
she had just come from bingo that day
and she was doing fine she went to bingo
she didn't play bingo
she was just counting the numbers or
helping people i don't know what she was
doing down there she's a big bingo chick
she's
retired that's what you do when you
retire you play bingo in those small
communities so
i went down there again and then about a
week ago i got a call that
they put her in the [__] hospital
again and that uh
the cancer is all over her body and that
they're giving her a little time and
that
uh you know we're all gonna go down and
meet they're gonna put her in
the hospice she wants to die at home
so they're gonna put her at home you
know when i got that call
you know i called like i called joan my
sister
i called my brother mike you know i was
a little bit emotional
you guys know me i get emotional about
that [__]
but then i put it in perspective i go
you know what there's no reason for me
to get emotional i'm gonna go down there
and talk to her that's it how many
[__] chances
do you have to go talk to somebody and
tell them how you feel
not a lot especially before they punch
the ticket not a lot
you know so i went down there i didn't
know
saturday my daughter had a softball game
and after the softball game
we hung out with some parents and i had
a [__] you know
i had to say goodbye because i had to go
down and had to meet mike and you know
uh bobby and [__] ricky and
[Music]
mike's daughters were down there so i
just want to go down there for mike
you know for me i wanted to see mike
also they've all been vaccinated you
could go in the house unless you were
vaccinated
you had to wear a mask you know i got
down there saturday
i uh saw mike
you know i hugged him and [__] you know
and then i went inside
and i saw her and i got to tell you guys
[__] cancer is no [__] joke
you know easter was four weeks ago
last time i saw it was two weeks ago
in those two weeks i don't know what the
[__] happened
but it just ran through a [__] body
so i went inside with mike first and we
sat with her and talked
and she was in and out you know
not really hearing you
you know i cover the feet i grabbed her
hands and then i went back outside
because i wanted to go back inside with
it i just wanted to be alone with her
so i went outside with mike i sat him
down i had an edible for him in the car
so i gave it to him
and then i went inside and i had my
chance with her
and i sat next to her the dog was on the
floor i pet the dog
and her hand was holding on to the
railing because they got her in like a
medical bed
so i held held onto a hand and i told
her that
uh i was a lost kid in 1981
i had nothing going on i didn't know
what the [__] to expect
you know when somebody invites you to
live with them
when you're a kid you're like well i
guess it's time to get raped
with time to get molested you know this
is what the boy scouts is for to prep
you for this [__]
i didn't know what the [__] to think you
know but
listen they were they treated me like
they treated all five of those [__]
boys
you know they treated i went right into
the house and i fit
right into that [__] house and
they looked after me you know i lived
there for a whole summer
they never asked me for a dime finally
in september mr ronnie said
either you go back to school or you get
a job i don't care what you do
but you either gotta go to school and
get free
rent or you have a job and pay rent
so i quit school my senior year
you know i didn't see any sense in going
back
so uh you know i paid them rent and i
ended up staying there till
i ended up living there for about 18
months with them until i robbed the
jewelry store and i didn't leave there
in a bad way i left there because i
didn't want the cops harassing them
mrs ronnie now she wasn't a crossing
guard no more
she had become a sheriff so i didn't
want to put in a position
for her to have to [__] arrest me so
she
she was a hudson county sheriff so i'm
like [__] the conflict
no yeah i'm living with a cop you know
she's probably gonna get the report and
she's gonna have to be you know
in a [__] in a country you know
whatever you call it in the [__]
because what the [__] i got this guy
living with me i can't arrest himself
i didn't want that to happen so i ended
up going to sarasota florida i wrote
them a hand
written letter before i left and i put
it on that bed i put
two weeks of rent in there you know
because that's the type of guy i am
and i [__] went to florida and i
didn't call him for the six weeks i was
in florida
but when i came back i went over there
we laughed about it
and here we are 40 years later
i wasn't there for when bobby ronnie
died the father
i don't know where i was i think i was
doing time
and jones husband died and he was a dear
friend of mine
and i wasn't there for when he died
but i'm happy that i'm here for mrs
ronnie
i'm really happy i went down there now
the whole time
that i was talking to her i told her i
was a lost kid
thank you thank you for treating me like
a mother thank you for giving me a
mother's love
you know i told all the things i was
supposed to i apologize to her
for causing ruckus in the house you know
i tried to even loosen it up
mr ronnie when he was alive his mother
died
and i went out that night and got drunk
and he had a suit
hanging up next to the chair all ironed
and steamed to wear to the funeral
and i decided to drink vodka and orange
juices that night so i'm sitting in his
chat also and i just started heaving
puke
and i puked on his suit and they were
pissed at me for two days
so i even apologized to her for that i'm
i'm sorry for puking on mr runny suit
the week of his mother's funeral you
know i'm sorry for all the craziness
but i love you i told everything she
squeezed my hand a little bit
she didn't say much her lips were just
quivering
and she squeezed my hands a little bit
and
that was it i was good to go i got i got
to say goodbye
i got to thank her for what she had done
i walked out i hugged mike
we talked a little more you know they
sparked the number
i had to drive so i didn't want to smoke
so i didn't smoke
and then the weirdest [__] thing
happened i said all right i gotta say
goodbye to mom
now throughout the whole time i was in
there we had like a little eight-minute
chat she didn't [__] say nothing she
was just
quivering and whatever and i know she
was hearing my words
she just you know i could tell when she
squeezed my hands that she
was telling me thank you for saying
those things to me
but she hadn't said nothing so as we
were leaving
i hugged mike i go let me go say goodbye
to mom
i don't know if i'm going to have time
thursday or friday i'm going to try to
go back there again
i don't want to say that that was the
last time i'm gonna see her
you know i'm gonna try to go down there
again this weekend you know people
coming every day you know the only rule
is we gotta wear double mask
but uh
i'm happy i got to say goodbye to her
but when i went back inside
i said ma i'm probably going to come
back and see you
you know if you need something tell
bobby let him call me i'll leave bobby
my number
just remember i love you and all this
and i don't know where she goes
i love you too she uttered the words
and then she fell back to sleep
i [__] walked out of there just
blown the [__] away you know i had to
show my strength
for the boys like i had to walk out of
there and show like nothing like nothing
happened
they didn't ask what happened i didn't
say nothing it was between me and mrs
ronnie
i walked out i hugged them i talked to
them for a little while
and then i got my car and drove home and
i got to tell you guys
i mean for me i lost my parents when i
was 16. i don't have to sweat it anymore
you know that was a loss for me that was
a lost media day
and i had to think about something this
is [__] interesting as [__] because
what would you rather do find your mom
like i did on the floor and not be able
to say goodbye to her
or see your mom die slowly and suffer
i it's it's just a horrible [__]
situation for us
as men and women that you know we have
to do this
to our parents i mean i think it's
[__]
terrible listen my mom went away i
didn't have a chance to say goodbye to
her
she gave me a couple clues some things
that i hold on till today
you know i got a chance to say goodbye
to marilyn martinez
and right there from her death bed she
told me that god didn't want me to do
coke
and i bought into it i never did coke
again you know
i was very happy that i got to say
goodbye to maryland
and i got to be honest here i really
really really
wanted to apologize to mrs bender before
she passed she passed
i sent flowers hopefully i'll get the
strength
someday in the boss to knock on their
door and apologize to the kids
i talked to the one brother we're still
tight but i'm happy i had the
opportunity
to go down to mrs ronnie on saturday and
if you guys know anything about me
and the ronnie family you know that it
meant the world to me guys
it meant the world to me to be able and
for her to say that she loved me at the
end after our conversation
that was as good as it gets in my
[__] world guys so
i understand you now when you guys hit
me on patreon and when you guys hit me
on instagram
or hit me on [__] facebook and
tell me the light of prayer that your
parents are going down or a sister or a
brother
well now i'm part of the [__] club
you know i lost a sister-in-law
you know during all this who i was very
tight with
who helped me a ton with [__] comedy
in the very beginning
and now i'm going to lose the lady who
took me in
in 1981 but you know what i [__]
went down there with honor you know
and i'm happy i came back
and i'm happy that i became the man that
i
am today you know i got problems and
[__]
we all do but
i i became a man uh whatever you guys
may think of
what the definition of a man is is is
i'm really happy about that it has made
my [__] week
and i'll go down there again you know
i'm prepared i'm prepared for a funeral
now
i'm prepared for awake because i got to
say what i want to say you know
uh when i get the call that something
happens to her i'm sure i'll be a little
upset
you know but i'll keep it together
because
i got to be strong for the family i got
to be strong for the boys
i got to show them you know mike is a
mess he already lost his wife
this so he's going to lose a wife and a
mom
within a [__] year i i i wouldn't
even want to [__] be him
i i wouldn't even want to know what that
[__] feels like but
it's a part of life we all gotta deal
with it
and now i gotta deal with it i'm happy i
got you guys so we could laugh
we could keep doing this [__] [__]
all the time and uh
i get this off my chest this makes life
a lot [__] easier for me
to do this on a [__] podcast because
my whole goal with the church and the
joint was to never talk down to you guys
it was always
to let you know that we all put our
pants on one leg at a time
i just became a [__] comedian and i
got lucky
i'm not better than you i'm not about
anybody we're all the [__] same
i was a criminal till [__] 20 [__]
years ago
but you're never too big to [__]
apologize you're never too big to
say thank you you're never too big to
let people know what they've done for
you you know
i let people know what they've done for
me i thank them you know i
i thank them and i let them know it's
sincerity
and authenticity that i mean it from the
bottom of my heart
you know and uh that's it man
you know when i went to see marilyn and
and i went to
i didn't know it was the last time i was
gonna see her we had a little talk back
and forth and she said that to me
and in my world between us i took that
as a direct message from
god look i stopped doing [__] blow
and look where i am 13 years later i got
a [__] life i got a kid i got a wife
and everything is all right you know i'm
not able to do stand-up right now i
don't know how i feel about stand-up
but when that comes back and i'm ready
i'll be ready you'll see me out there
you know i'm getting all these offers
and [__] like that for stand up
and this is what you guys don't
understand
it takes six months for me to write an
hour
i would love to lie to you guys and tell
you ha ha
you know i can write an hour and three
months and perform it no it doesn't
no don't if you guys want me to go out
let me know
i love to go out you know what i'm 58 i
could charge 40
and go out there and do an improvised
[__] set
and not give a [__] where the piece is
for and tell you [__] to go
[__] yourself
any of you guys have known that have
seen me tour
in the last 10 [__] years every time
you saw me
my pride was that i showed up with new
material
i showed up in at least 30 to 40 minutes
of new [__] material
i didn't give you the same [__] over and
over again
and i'm very proud of that when i was a
stand-up i took that very [__]
seriously
i did i didn't go to the same areas
every eight months
take you with the same jokes to make
money i could have done that i could
have came to your club twice in a year
and milked you and it could have been
over with
right now i'm 58 years old i could just
set up a [__] tour tomorrow
for 40 50 tickets have you guys come
down
i go up there and talk [__] for an hour
i can talk [__] for [__] an hour
every day
are you guys going to be happy with me
not really you're going to leave that
going [__]
joe rogan says this guy's a [__]
savage we just saw half a [__] up there
we just saw some [__]
wounded deer up there that's why i'm not
doing stand-up
i don't want to take your [__] money
for me to take your money and do that
that's not fair
but i could do that i could set up a
world tour if you like
i could go to dayton i'd go to [__]
columbus i go to chicago i go whatever
the [__] you want
i don't have to work on anything and i
can just come charge you 40 bucks you
guys will pay a seven dollar
ticket charge because i don't care about
you and i just go up there and eat
[__] and not do anything after that i
could do that too if you want me to do
that
i could do that that's not what i'm
gonna [__] do i'm not going out
until i work out until i'm ready to go
and i know i have 50 to an hour
that you guys are gonna be proud to see
you guys gonna be proud to take a
picture of me afterward
you're gonna be proud on top of that i
don't want to go out and sit in between
[__] the room
in the shows why go to a show if i can't
see you [__]
we haven't seen each other now in
[__] a year since the pandemic
and however long before that before i've
been to your town i think the last
couple dates i did were
vegas tempe atlanta
san francisco i did in december with
dean
after new year's i think i did new york
city in december so you guys haven't
seen me
in a while and i did miami for
thanksgiving
and something before that date before
that
i have you haven't seen me but any time
i did a [__] show
the only place i felt i really [__]
hate a bag of dixon there's only one
city
that i think i ate a bag of dicken
that's new orleans
when i did it with steve simone in 2019
june 7th and 2019 that was not a good
[__] show
i don't know what happened to me i could
name the shows i got him written down
the [__] notebook how about that for
you
because you guys know i journal
everything so after i get off stage
i will put [__] columbus ohio show
one show two show three show four show
five
and i will write how i did there's ton
you know when i did a weekend in the
comedy club there would always be one
show
where i would just go off the deep end
just on purpose because
guys kept coming people would buy
tickets for two nights and i would go
why are you doing that
you're gonna see the same [__]
material that [__] kills me as a
comic
i would hate for you to come see me and
go you know what we came to see this
[__] 18 months ago
and he's talking about the same [__]
this is a bust out
so i always always wrote my set list out
when i was
let's say i'm in columbus [__] in may of
2021 i will
i won't write out the whole joke list
but i will write the jokes you know gabe
bob
sucking my dick with ice cubes in your
mouth you know like i'll
i'll give you the bullet points so i
know exactly when i come back to your
town
what not to touch on you understand me
that's what professional does
who did i learn it from uncle joey
nobody else told me that
i just knew i didn't want you to pay 25
bucks if you always notice i kept my
tickets low
i'm not in business to rip nobody off
i'm a thief by nature
but you guys i pampered i never [__]
charge over 25 bucks
30 maybe in a club because the club was
like oh you could get away with 30.
but if i charge 30 i knew i had a
[__] smoking [__] hour
it's 25 for [__] me for the shows
and 20 for workouts that's [__] fair
you know what i'm working on if you want
to give 20 bucks that's nothing
20 bucks or nothing i go up there i'll
still give you a great show
you know you're not gonna know what
you're gonna get before i go on a road
i'd rather have a [__] solid hour so
when you guys see me
you're happy i'm not gonna go on the
road to a half [__] audience
it's not worth the aggravation so when
my leg heals up and i'm ready to [__]
feel good again
between you and i beside writing the
book with erica
we talked today and we talked yesterday
and we talked monday
we talked we try to talk four days a
week we're trying to speed up this
[__]
book to get it out there to you it's
gonna take a while it's not gonna say
you know
you just don't get a feather with some
[__] ink and write a book out like
this you know we talk every [__] day
and we make notes and at night i make
little [__] notes and
i send them to her and at least we know
what the [__] we're doing
you know i'm trying to write i've
written i'm not gonna lie to you
i have written a couple of little jokes
just little ones
maybe four of them they're not gonna
knock your [__] socks off they're not
gonna blow you out of the water
but you gotta start somewhere and you
know why i've written those jokes
i've been writing them because i think
of them as i'm playing the guitar
dude i tell you so do you understand me
for you to create you have to be
entertained we go back to that frame of
thought
i am entertaining myself with the guitar
and while i am playing the guitar i have
a notebook next to me and i write little
things
it's because i'm goofing on myself why
i'm playing the guitar well i'm playing
the guitar i'm like
i am the worst guitar player in the
[__] world i know the beginning of
back and black
i'm working on a little bit of nutshell
which sounds horrible
on the [__] amp and i'm working on a
little bit of brain stew
by uh by green day
damn that's a [__] i got to
stretch the pinky
this one the power core i don't know
nothing and like i told the teacher to
say listen
my fingers have been practiced you know
i'm not a pimp no more my fingers
i haven't finger banged anybody in years
you know when you have to stick your
finger a little monkey and then you have
to work that pinky with the [__] the
whole [__] thing get the tinfoil
yeah i've been out of that [__]
circuit for 20 [__] years you know i
haven't fingered nobody i got a wife now
i don't need to finger people
so you know sorry about that
i'm sorry to my wife uh what i'm trying
to say is when you got a wife you need
to finger people you know what i'm
saying you just go right to the heart of
the matter
so my fingering is off is what i'm
trying to say like when i was [__] 30
and [__] i was fingering chicks two
finger louie with the pinky drawer
you know what i'm saying that's
tremendous because you're fingering them
and you got that little pinky and then
muffler whether you go sideways or
whatever we shouldn't be discussing this
what i'm trying to say is my fingers are
out of the [__] uh
yeah whatever the [__] i got that little
uh so
so mike got me the little [__] thing
and i've been working on that but still
it's a dexterity on my fingers even for
brain stew
it's like the [__] it's the it's
three
five so it's five and then seven
and then two oh my god and then i gotta
go up to three
and five and they get wider and then two
and three
and then one and three and then i go
back to the e
yeah right which is damn it right so
what the [__] you think you're dealing
with
you guys think uncle joey is not doing
his [__] homework i'm doing my
homework [__]
i'm just just work with me when i'm
ready i will pick this guitar up and
play it for you guys i promise you
the first people to see me play the
guitar will be patreon
and the next will be you [__]
okay i promise you
with all my heart but i've been working
on it and i have been
having a great [__] time so i want to
thank mike
i want to thank a lot of you
[__] who have been
so encouraging with the guitar if i knew
so many guitar people followed me i
would have done a guitar patreon
like five bucks people exchanged [__]
let's have a [__] good time videos i
just gotta figure out a way to send
[__] videos on there
i mean you guys are great and uh a lot
of you guys have offered me help offered
me
services and classes for free i love you
[__] for it mike as often
let me do this this is what happened
with jiu jitsu i took too much in and in
the end i didn't know [__]
let me learn the basics from my teacher
let me get
the [__] down you know i love
doing it i mean there's no i didn't know
i was gonna fall in love with it like
i've been doing like
i could tell when i don't play the
guitar that day yeah you're like i could
tell
like i could tell now like what the [__]
something's not right so
you know i i played dna when my daughter
was here my
dinner my daughter was goofing at me
she's like that don't sound like the
song you were looking to play
i was playing ac dc back in black and
she's like
it's like back and great dad it's not
black and black you know what i'm saying
it's like [__] if my daughter's goofing
on me i don't need this [__] in my life
but hey you gotta have a sense of humor
and uh
at least i'm having a great time so
thank you for all the people for your
encouragement you know
i've had a couple people that said go
[__] yourself you suck on the guitar
you know go kill yourself all that [__]
but all they saw was the [__]
blues
yeah but that doesn't no they didn't
even see [__] like a bluish
they just hate you know they just hate
you know you have no right to pick up
the guitar
how you gonna put the guitar over your
stomach you know everybody's always got
some [__] remark
and for you [__] who haven't
noticed uncle joey
has been losing a little [__] weight
if you haven't noticed this is one of
the sweatshirts left over from the
original [__] load
when i made the t-shirts they sent a
bunch of sweatshirts so i might as well
wear something great today i didn't want
to come up here with a blue little
[__] t-shirt on again
to wish you a happy monday it's
wednesday [__] the sky
is great now it's a beautiful day
outside in [__] jersey
but hey i wanted to check in with you
guys and tell you look
i have guests now i'm [__] trying
guys
i'm trying to go outside to normal it's
not like i've called kate quigley again
and george perez again and the same
people i've had on the church
and tried to shove him down your throat
i've gone out to a different
[__] series of people just just let
you know that
we're trying here this is called a
hybrid podcast
sometimes i'm going to come on sometimes
i'm going to come on with a guest
and sometimes it's just going to be a
[__] zoom how's that for you
[__]
i don't know we're going to do it as we
feel as it comes along
but it's not like i'm bringing you
[__] uh i'm
trying to bring you new blood guys you
know for me to show up with the same
people out in the church over and over
again
would just be a disaster i'm trying to
[__] make this podcast
[__] work thank you for the people
for all the encouragement on the podcast
on the joint you know that we're trying
we're just trying something different
you know what i'm saying a lot of people
don't like this guest a lot of people
got mad at this guest a lot of people
got mad at disgust guys
this is free i'm just trying to [__]
do something
to make your day go by a little easier
don't make this rough on everybody
so enjoy what you get today you got your
uncle joey i was missing you guys
more than you were missing me i saw some
of the comments you people like how come
you gotta have a guest
all the time okay then uncle joey will
make a comeback
and say hello to you [__]
personally you don't think i miss you
[__]
sure i miss you [__] i got a
big week i got she's got softball game
on saturday
she's got [__] batting practice
tonight the batting cages
you know i got a couple things going on
i got an nft card
coming out pretty [__] soon we're
working on that
for patreon i don't know if you guys
like heart
the nft things yeah the nfp card crypto
the crypto all right yeah
yeah they got a showman i'm gonna show
you a nice picture
and i'm gonna have those for you
[__] maybe for 20 bucks we'll
sell them
keep them light and uh so we're working
on that we're working on a couple things
and then we're working on
me not getting a blood clot and [__]
dying here so
you know yeah so i'll let you guys know
on monday
what they said about the antibody test
uh
see if i got any blood clots but i think
i'm all right i've been riding the
[__] bike every day
i i [__] started walking to
strengthen the knees so i go to a
a ball field every day and i [__]
walk around a few times
and i get a little vitamin d i wanted to
switch him up a little bit now the
weather's nice
but uh that's it and that's that man i'm
happy that you guys got a chance to
watch on wednesday
i'm happy you guys are enjoying what
we're doing here what we're trying to do
and uh keep coming back and keep hanging
out with us man you know i love you
[__]
with all my heart whether it's patreon
facebook twitter
instagram i got you [__] every
week you know like i said in the
beginning of this i put my pants on one
leg at a time
just like you [__] and i'm just
trying to push along
i hope you enjoy what we're doing here
we're trying our hardest and uh
the world's in a [__] place right now
the more smiles the better man so i love
you [__]
have a great week thank you for watching
this week and we'll be back on monday
i don't know if we're gonna have a guest
i'll [__] surprise you [__]
all right
stay black have a great week and here's
for a word for my [__] sponsors
love you thank you very much for
listening to the podcast today yes you
had your uncle joey for your [__]
time today no guest
i know half he is a happy no more
complaining but before i go
i gotta talk to you about two products
number one on it
the best when it comes to health you
understand me alpha brain shroom tech
new mood i love all three of them the
protein bites
the alpha brain powder i mean they have
stuff that you don't even know but you
got to go there and read
the mct oil they have a coconut almond
protein bar that is [__] tremendous
but it all starts with you going on it
they're going to have their semi-annual
sale
may 3rd through the 16th of may they can
slash in prices
get ready to drop a [__] load on on
it this is your chance right now
to work with a company to get the best
products available to you
alpha brain nootropics [__]
tremendous 100 percent money
back guarantee and they don't want the
product when the company does that
that's what i want to do business with
so do me a favor go to honnett.com right
now
read take a look at what shroom tech has
they have smaller containers big contain
whatever you need they got they're
putting stuff in powder now so you can
put it in your water
and just shake it up and work out with
it i mean on it's doing great things but
it all starts with you go to honor.com
right now
read you like something start with the
alpha brain
press in church and get 10 off delivered
right to your [__] house okay
the joint is also brought to you by zip
recruiter i love zip recruiter you know
why
because let them play matchmakers you
don't have to read through a thousand
applications
you know how hard it is to find a good
employee
it's like finding it's like looking for
a needle in the haystack but guess what
zip recruiter will find it in fact zip
recruit is so effective
that four out of five employers who post
on zip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day 2.3 million
businesses have already used
ziprecruiter
what are you waiting on yeah you can
post your job online on a cork board at
a coffee shop or some [__]
but then you just got to sit there and
hope the right person walks by and what
are the chances
stop dreaming smack yourself in the face
and try zip recruiter for free
at ziprecruiter.com joey why
because they do the work for you one
click and your job gets sent to over 100
of the top job sites and here's where it
gets crazy
that matching technology hooks you up
with the people with the
right skills and experience that you
need get
quality candidates fast let them look
for it
in fact zip recruiter is that effective
that four out of five employees
will get a quality candidate within the
first day do you understand what i'm
trying to say to you
so right now today you can try
ziprecruiter for your business whether
it's small or large
at ziprecruiter.com joey again
that's ziprecruiter.com joey try it for
free just by going to ziprecruiter.com
joey save time money and energy
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire i
want to thank all you guys this week on
it zip recruiter cbd lion who's having
that 420 sale
don't forget to click on their link next
tuesday they're going to blow your mind
i want to thank everybody who supported
us i want to thank
my man alessandro who was on monday go
give it a watch and that tick tock
suckers have a great weekend
uncle joey loves you and we'll be back
monday morning
tip top magoo
i love you [__] stay black have a
good weekend
you